Listen carefully, if the lives of the people of the human kingdom are important, then let go
of my disciples.
Now, what will
happen to that silence? People of the people, you are the same people as Adonis. I didn't want to fight. If I destroy him, that's
where he should return someday.  That's
why I kept you alive. You've
seen too much. The
magic is
gone. You witches. You can't understand it, and you
never even thought about the power of science that we have. We who should have helped you all this time.
When it comes to being chased by humans,
why do they have to
share a world where magic
can't be used? A witch who can't use magic is just a woman.
What are you hiding from Mirei Witch Ra? You can't come here. But you did it.
No, wait, I'm
going over there now. It's too loud.
Do it.